amici miei oggi siamo in una domenica
arrivo con jam jam ma gianpi sto
chiamando perché sto pensando gia
li facciamo amici miei siamo in rua
domenica con gianandrea e siamo al
sequel di the titans o blogging ci tengo
a precisare che non lo stiamo
registrando lo stesso giorno non io
soltanto sei maglioni tutti uguali e
niente quindi adesso giochiamo il sequel
di tyson loving che si chiama gravity
bond perché lo avesse visto molte
riprese la wii mi lascio magari linking
descrizione che mi dimenticherò
sicuramente di mettere che quindi non
troverete con un quindi iscrizione a
bilancio i mandarini immagina
esattamente questa canzone di sottofondo
certo io rifarei l'inizio 20 volte però
va ripetendo vado a settare di nuovo i
colli
ok
non li sebbene non sentiamo non li
sentiamo né avanti così è in realtà il
fatto che si accasciato e perché volevo
riascoltare la musica e vogliamo fare un
po di salsa
grazie a dio siamo gli spazi ristretti
non possiamo farla del saturday club
io sono sempre una spia sì devo andare
nella stanza della fornace questa qua è
una festa che mi ci sono infiltrate ho
capito e sono hanno tutti la mascherina
che la festa in maschera esatta una
festa in maschera sono sempre tutti
vogliosi di vivere
l'altro è curioso vedere che ci sono
degli idrovolanti già belli al khali
anzi per decorare ecco la forniscono una
volta sono uccidere solo bravissimo ma
sai che a caso ho fatto sta roba non
dicono mai fossero presso spesso space
pasto jam garanzie ok o la valigia
nascosta eccoci qua entriamo in funzione
questo drink all'uomo coi capelli rossi
non mi devo anche vestire dalla pretesa
lui ci dà le istruzioni tramite una
valigia che trasmette si fa un po unione
sovietica
complimenti sa prova prova a guardare
esattamente in basso come il bicchiere
non si muove rilavorate di niente però
c'è una cimice nel bicchiere è vero sono
le nanomacchine quelle di uno
scarafaggio scarafaggi sigla avevo fatto
anche nel primo video di cavi tipo non
rifarlo da voglio vedere la faccia di
alfred che altro per capire un attimo
come come era conciata è sempre per per
la scienza voglio solo vedere che
succede se ti butti giù non è che volevo
farlo veramente sono annunci esplodi e
poi a puoi morire qua a ok a c'era
l'auto 6 va bene va bene era per capire
cosa succedeva la scusami adesso perché
andiamo detto quindi doveva trovare
l'uomo coi capelli rossi tra tutti
questi non lo vedo
l'uomo quindi non è una donna no infatti
di man sarà su cinque ha uno che sarà in
cima alle scale saiano piano eccolo a
era di ed sheeran edifici ma non venderò
quello che mi sa di esatto è la guardia
del corpo
scusi
sono stato bravissimo ciao
se ne è accorto mi sa sì ma per unito
però va bene chissà cosa sta facendo
questo sulla testa del mio del pacchetto
vabbè salve signor finalmente esatto
ciao amico mio e tanto la principessa di
va bene è la madonna salute trova
all'uscita ci ecco la domanda se ti
butti da soli ci saranno i semi dacca 26
sicuro
ecco lo scopriamo subito si sono caduto
sulla testa di altre persone tra loro
stanno benissimo senza dubbio sempre
usciti a morire due volte in un gioco
dove non di base non si muore quindi
glielo ha dato almeno no è però
godiamoci la musica senti bari per venti
volte
arriviamo fino a lì quindi se proprio a
passare davanti alla guardia del corpo
non ti dice niente
no ma chiaramente non mi dice niente
eccoci calde allora scendiamo un secondo
nella maniera più normale che esista
perché sono qua moriamo
peccato che poi morire il suo gioco va
bene
troviamo l'uscita ovviamente passando
sulle persone perché è tutto molto
divertente però una bella festa
meno bene se la gente si diverte non è
male di compagnia e tipo spy parti exit
zone come mai nei giochi facciamo noi
due c'è sempre qualche spia e qualche
parte forse c'è qualcosa che vorrei
dirti ma non posso va bene ragazzi sta
diventando molto difficile giocare con
jean non lo dico io scusa una chiamata
al codec e dunque mi hanno pagato 3.400
dollari per quella kill a quella per
quella 3.400 senza tasse diventasse ci
ha scritto aisin tyson troutman ma c'è
la tipa della micra
no no non è rita e quell'altra un cupo
lato la pace onlus moments momenti senza
senza passione e beh si vede che non è
un'appassionata d'angolo roma
aaron hofer tower 77 70 esimo piano
cerca di prey del gol
se vai sempre nella frutta la fornace
bene nella fornace ma perché lo rosa
ecco la loro lasciano in indizi nella
stanza la fornace
non so di andare sotto senza farsi
schiacciare
bravo molto bene abbiamo presso rights
freon e martello forli showroom a devo
prima usare questo ok very good e orari
spunterò stessa cosa che poi è cambiato
un po l'ambiente non è una festa
mi sembra presidenti vol ma in italia
incontriamo in questo ma chi lo so
potrebbe essere morta no spagnoli non è
nemmeno detto che noi siamo stesso
personaggio è vero questa fotografa
cinque celle
quali non voglio saperlo però intanto
stava rompendo la videocamera massa ha
poi anche sul mare se vuoi credo davvero
no è solo un png che tristezza
io non so neanche i pantaloni allora
fotografia mosti uccelli dai madonna di
addirittura doppio sposano tutto e poi
dargli una bella chiavi stellata ovvero
fate che fa tutto montato l'her2 è vero
devi fotografare della roba e poi di
congelare dell'altro esatto cosa che
congelava a sé le bombe con berg hansen
che bello per un ciellina si è carina ma
no ora mourinho ma così è successo
benito torna tutto e fat man era erano
piombo esatto
no ragazzi incredibile c'è nel senso
quindi non sono uccelli veri
evidentemente no ma perché che senso ha
questa roba perché degli uccelli
dovrebbero esplodere se li potrei non
simboli di un lanciamissili noi non sono
uccelli sono uccelli creati dal governo
wrobel è già certo sono armi di
distruzione di massa da roma per
sorpassare il metal gear sempre guarda
credo ci sia un altro uccello a dentri
che nessun sito guardate che coincidenza
ciao lei mancano due nella caduta
allora qua porca vacca qua io salverei
la partita se si può salvare
perché secondo me ti devi arrampicare
link eh sì sono bravo altroc assassin's
creed
vabbè ma tesi ormai esperto di migranti
mamma mia mamma mia
ok però anche non salvare incredibile ci
sono gli ultimi decenni e quindi spero
che mi paghino sempre 3.400 dollari
maschi sarebbe anche di più sarebbe
utile bensì per degli uccelli io mi
farei pagare anche di più a quella
stanza la fornace di scusa scusa dov'eri
quando ha indotti a posso uscire ok ok è
chiaro chiaro ci siamo un collegio entra
qualcosa di così si sa che l'unica non
abbiano caso no
no sono stato anch'io novecento
questa nuova ricordavo c'entrava vero ma
no veri che cavolo torna tutto sarà vano
me la ricordavo davvero ti prendi ha
fregato anche prendere la macchina
fotografica e queste donne con fede ai
ragazzi
queste donne sono seguito ma posso
seguirla viene mirror's edge porca vacca
quanto difficile dai che poi alla fine
ha fatto fare tutto a me e poi è
arrivata sin certo molti fan così
complimenti sia effettivamente alla
ricci pensione vero marca vacca ok qua
secondo me tra voi due finisce è
presente quella classica rivalità tra
spie tipo mi sia sei mesi smith fine ci
limoni guarda si può una prostata
canestro intuire la un po beffarda
incredibile e trama ragazzi dato la
musica di sottofondo
scusate ragazzi non lo so non volevo
ottonato folli salve mi ha fregato
incredibilmente se la sono studiata
benissimo scusate ragazzi è più buono
così il cibo però al sicuro eccola è
velocissima che teloni e me lo
immaginavo
no dai non può finire così questa non è
successo
perché esplode tutto insolito gioco sono
fresco e ti farò moglie che moriva può
essere tu che scappati inseguiti sparano
[Musica]
vanità
in tutto questo eccola e lei no beh
forse non è in forza non è nido a nostra
moglie era 11 corridori gen
ah beh chiaramente la morale se quella
del mandarino questa è che nella vita
devi correre nella tua corsia lei sempre
correre e mai guardarti indietro ma
sempre per stare attenzione a che cosa
si cela dietro l'angolo perché potresti
trovare il successo con la tua fine
[Musica]